And as you might expect, in fact as you
told me offline that you did expect,
what we're going to do is Vt is defined
using the Bellman update, right,
the Bellman equation in terms of Vt-1.
So what we're going to do is structure
things around that Bellman equation.
So what I've done here is broken up the
Bellman equation into kind of kind of
a series of steps.
Vt(b) if the max over actions of
something, what is that something?
That something is the sum over all
observations of something else.
And what is that something else?
That turns out to be the sum over all
states of the reward function for
that state of given that
action times the belief state.
And then normalized by
the number of observations plus
the discounted expected
value of the next state.
The expectation comes
over the observation z.
And then the value the next state is
Vt-1 of the state estimation of b, a,
z, all right?
So this is really just
the Bellman equation.
But I kind of unrolled it, I guess,
or kind of un-telescoped it so
that each of these operations' going to
be easier to build out of vectors.
>> Okay, so the sum of the s is just for
the thing on the left side of the plus.
>> Yes.
>> Right, because it's just the reward.
>> Right, and what's going to happen is
this side is also going to have a sum
over s in it, weighted by b(s).
>> Mm-hm.
>> And
that's going to allow us to actually
think about this whole thing as a dot
product of the belief state
with some kind of messy vector.
>> Okay, I like messy vectors.